well I guess there are a lot of
festivities that are being planned for
this this big event to commemorate just
what happened well I thought with the
holidays here and the good feeling and
the cheer everywhere it was time to get
another group of stars together and
record a new tune to help people in
these times and well I for one I'm very
proud of the results that we got and I'd
like to share it with you right now take
a look at at our little effort
[Music]
I think it's just a chance for us to
sort of do our part this is our our
chance to sort of put ourselves on the
line put ourselves to the test
reach out help people and you know we'll
figure out the exact cause later on but
right now just to sort of help just get
in that hole helping thing we just want
to raise enough money to help out
whatever cause we end up choosing just
to sort of help I've been saying look
it's not like we're just gonna choose
some specific cause you know like hey
this song is you know for cancer and the
rest of you can just go to hell
that's not what we're about we're about
just helping in general recording just
gave me like a time and an address I
didn't know it was for a song or
anything and I have this friend in town
visiting and we were supposed to go to
lunch but when I found out that it was
about helping people you know I just I
couldn't say no and besides we've got
sandwiches so I mean it all worked out
okay people I just settled down
everybody let's figure out who's here
and and who still to come max okay
you're here Andy yeah I'm fine all right
get that up if you can phil collins is
phil collins here
anyone seen Poe Collins Tina Turner
Tina trying to show up Huey Lewis
where's Werth Huey Lewis
what Huey Lewis couldn't make it what's
he doing
alright Boy George whereas deceased oh
he's alive
boy boy so people should is it the door
well marked
Tina Turner yep Tina turn around well
who is right now who's here is uh okay
we got max you're here max is here
okay max and Andy yeah all right well
we're Conan asked me to be a part of
this great event I said of course I work
for Conan well this is uh this is pretty
much it we had some last-minute that no
she'll sit yeah but we're in great shape
I mean let me introduce you to the guys
we're in great shape come on in I want
you to meet you know max right it's kind
of more of a drummer than a singer but
it's all about this effort this is Andy
right there this is our oldie oldie this
is oldie also be home yeah oldie plays
on Drive sort of dream that I'm playing
for it's really nice to come out at hi
over and this is uh this is a friend of
Andy's he's actually pretty good singer
he's okay he's better than max what is
it Marsh well this is yeah and then we
got um yeah you do um just as I think
you do other voices like you do a Phil
Collins yeah you do other than Phil
Collins or any impressions I don't okay
sure I can do this oh come on what do
you thought we got everybody here I mean
we went to if I you know it's gonna be
great and we're gonna actually
Kathy I think we should don't we have
someone else to go you just talk right
into that microphone they're just one
line which line up it's uh well I think
this is the best for you help with your
knees you know that's it's some you know
you're like using every part of yourself
to help
[Music]
when folks need our help
we gotta make time to help gotta reach
out and let them a hand
yes we got to help each other mr. uncle
and brother animals too if we can so
help with your hands with your heart
and help with your hair and your hair
[Music]
help with your knees
[Music]
help
[Applause]
[Music]
got to do what's right by the children
the infants and the day with a white
green yellow
[Music]
baby got to help and heaven itself as
they help others more helping them right
back if you got to help people people
[Music]
I'm worried about Cohen's choice I mean
it's not so much a singing it's just
like a hammy you know he over sells
things and I was wondering if you could
talk to him you know ya know he seems
very committed to the park you know
right right yeah woman yeah you been in
the music business for a while you could
you know maybe just tell him to take it
down a notch
you know he sort of just suggested to
get within the group framework a bit
more yeah yeah would you do that no yeah
you know I don't think we need Huey
Lewis actually I think it's really
really going great
well there there's one thing I wanted to
talk to you about in it yeah sure the
part of the song where you know you get
all worked up that I want to say yeah I
want to say yeah maybe maybe sting
should sing that part you just see it
just seems like kind of a natural for
him
yeah yeah I guess he I don't know
sting really thought of that was like a
singing guy like he's bass player I just
sort of have like if it's not you know
if it's not broke don't don't think well
I know I know I just I think that we
should probably steer clear of the song
being grading
raining really what it's like is this an
ambush I mean no no no I mean we're
friends enough if you're doing a little
mind thing on me are you mad about
something are you mad thank you
if this is are you mad I mean we moved
the chair a little away from the desk it
was for lighting I just I don't know I
guess I feel you know betrayed well it's
just I just I just I just feel a little
betrayed but I mean he's sting fine fine
let's what what just but maybe just yeah
sting just let's make it all about
like people really want to see sting
[Music]
[Applause]
to do
because unless we do
[Music]
yes together we will work
[Music]
some good can I thank the stinker for
all this help alright ladies gentlemen
hang on to your seats gonna be right
back with Jon Lovitz what say you in
just a minute